- All right, mom I gotta go.
I have to pick Jackson up
and I gotta find my phone.
Yes, I realize I'm on the phone!
- We are supposed to tell mommy
when it's somebody's birthday
because now we don't
have a gift for Jessica
and she's gonna think I'm a bad mommy.
Oh, do you still play with this?
Tag's still on it.
- Gross cold coffee.
And there's yesterday's.
- What, I don't feel like washing a glass.
- Yeah, yeah, I'm on my way.
Yeah, I'm in the car already.
Yeah, no, I'll be there, oh.
I'll be there in a second.
Uh-huh, yeah, no, totally.
I'll remember the muffins.
- Where?
Oh!
This is the one we already had.
Where's your other shoe?
(upbeat music)
- What?
Oh my God.
Oh my God, I'm on my way!
- (bleep), I'm so late.
- Oh my God, God dammit,
get mommy's keys, we're late.
Get in the car!
- Oh God, what is that?
(bleep) Still in my pyjamas?
Whatever.
- Who has time to make muffins
for a bake sale anyway, right.
- Karen.
- Karen, oh (bleep) Karen's coming.
- Store bought ladies?
- Only the best.
- Karen's a real bitch,
you know what I'm saying?
- I'm Karen, I do kegels every day.
- I do kegels every day,
I'm such a good mom, I've
never dropped my kid.